when will slapped chris he slapped all
of us but he really slapped me
why do you say that
because when you hurt my child you hurt
me
chris rock's mom rose rock speaks out on
the controversial oscar slap as the
source fills in et on how the comic is
doing since the infamous night
[Laughter]
the insider tells et quote chris is
really in a groove right now and is
building up material for a netflix
special
he continued to remain focused on his
show and not addressed the slap
personally but he's very close with his
mother and respects what she has to say
the truth is the assault really did
impact a lot of people not just chris
the source adds that chris is aware of
the other stars who have started
speaking out about it and taking sides
but he isn't getting caught up in that
he's sort of operating in a bubble right
now staying quote laser focused on his
work
when it comes to his work our source
says he's been tweaking his quote
addressing it without addressing it
opening bid and most recently he opened
his act by saying quote i'm alright
right i'm alright i've healed from the
bruises there was also a quote really
funny moment that happened in a show
recently where he asked an audience
member her name and she said quote jada
and he said quote sit your ass down and
the place erupted with laughter
back at the table this is gonna be an
exciting one speaking of jada she is
back at the red table her red table talk
show returned for a new season last week
and while the first episode addresses
janelle monae's sexuality jada in the
show took a moment to address the
elephant in the room by sharing a
message prior to the start of the
episode it reads quote considering all
that has happened in the last few weeks
the smith family has been focusing on
deep healing some of the discoveries
around our healing will be shared at the
table when the time calls
until then the table will continue
offering itself to powerful inspiring
and healing testimonies like that of our
incredibly impressive first guest
thanks for joining us jada
if we don't talk about it
we're not going to get to the other side
the premier episode for season five was
filmed before the infamous oscars
incident which led to the academy
banning will from all official events
for 10 years
in a statement to et the 53-year-old
king richard starr responded to the
ruling saying quote i accept and respect
the academy's decision
following the academy banning will et
spoke with billy porter who revealed why
the incident overall was quote upsetting
to him as a black queer man
um
you know it's a really rough one for me
it's a really rough one for me you know
because
i don't know that i have the authority
to speak on it
but as a black queer man who has been
dragged through the mud for not being
masculine enough
in this world
you know
being called the cause of the
emasculation of the black man because i
decide to play with feminine silhouettes
in my clothing
it's really disheartening
that the version of masculinity shows up
like that
it's upsetting